[Musique]
pour la dernière fois dans une casserole
avec un peu d'eau et puis toi tu vas me
couper les 100 g de beurre tu peux
prendre un couteau ma puce alors à c'est
un cadeau qui nous est arrivé vraiment
par hasard quand rimena mon ami m'a
parlé de ce qu'elle avait entendu à
l'église avec cette femme du Secours
Catholique qui avait demandé des
familles d'accueil pour les vacances et
elle m'avait dit que c'était trop
tard tout de suite j'ai été sur internet
et j'ai fait des mails à toutes les
associations la première qui m'a répondu
c'est le Secours Catholique et qui m'a
dit désolé on ne peut pas c'est trop
tard venez à la Réunion d'octobre ou je
sais plus trop quoi et là-dessus il y a
eu cette histoire avec mon amie qui m'a
dit benah moi j'ai un petit garçon qui a
une petite sœur et c'est de là que c'est
parti j'ai un peu peur de du côté
missionnaire vous voyez conquistador qui
veut aller prêcher la Bonn parole de
Jésus j'avais cette idée là vous voyez
du Secours Catholique et maintenant je
trouve ça super vraiment vraent c'est
ils sont très bien suivi les dossiers
sont très bien
faits
partout on s tous concerté en famille
mon mari mes deux garçons et puis on a
tous décidé que c'était une belle
aventure et que voilà donc on allait
accueillir Awa à la maison et ça a été
une grande excitation et puis quand on
s'est retrouvé à Versailles pour le lieu
de la rencontre on avait amené notre
labrador on était un peu complexé parce
qu'en fait on savait qu'elle avait été
dans une famille avec plein de petites
filles avant et là il se trouvait que
notre fils aîné était en stage à
étranger et Nathan était pas encore
arrivé donc on a amené de labrra d'or et
ça a fait te tout de suite parce qu'on
avait vu que dans son dossier elle
aimait les animaux et donc elle nous a
suivi et en fait elle a suivi le chien
surtout puis depuis bah c'est un régal
on apprend à se connaître elle est
adorable et nous ça nous apporte
beaucoup et en fait on on pensait lui
apporter beaucoup mais elle nous apporte
vraiment beaucoup aussi et tous en
famille c'est une belle découverte il y
a beaucoup de connivance entre nous on
s'entend très bien on est très câine on
vit entre femmes dans ce milieu d'hommes
parce qu'il n'y a que des hommes dans
cette famille et c'est vraiment très
sympa je suis choquée par le regard des
autres ça c'est sûr on est dans un monde
qui euh qui qui qui aime pas la
différence et ça tous les jours dans la
rue j'avoue que j'ai les les les les les
crocs qui poussent mais c'est que du
bonheur à faire vraiment c'est que de la
joie et vraiment on avait au départ
c'est donner de la joie donner du
bonheur aider mais en fait c'est c'est
c'est c'est encore plus important en
retour ça se passe super bien je suis
très contente de venir ici je suis
tranquille je m'amuse bien pourquoi tu
es pourquoi tu dis tu es tranquille
parce que tu es pas tranquille à la
maison non pourquoi parce qu'il y a trop
de bruit surtout les voisins ouais et
hier soir on a commencé à faire du
jardinage
on avait acheté deux plantes qu'on a
planté
là-bas et après c'était super
joli je suis très contente de venir ici
et avec Nathan avec Nathan ça va est-ce
qu'il t'embête des fois non non il est
gentil j'étais parti en vacances dans le
sud de la France je suis arrivé dimanche
quand je l'ai vu elle était était un peu
timide mais vraiment super sympa et par
contre au fil des jours
elle
s'est on va dire elle a plus parlé et
elle a plus communiqué on a pu jouer
ensemble cétait vraiment super sympa
hier le matin à la piscine on s'est bien
amusé c'était super fait il m'a fait
apprendre
un voilà
derrière
elle voulait manger une pizza bah ma
pizza en fait il restait que une part
pour moi et
là j'ai vu à ses yeux que
elle voulait vraiment la part de pizza
si elle avait pas boudé je l' aurais
donné toute la part de pizza quoi ici
quand on dit non c'est pas le moment où
tout de suite elle va se mettre à bouder
parce que hier on en est même arrivé au
point de dire si tu Boutes comme ça tout
le temps ça veut dire que tu es
malheureuse donc je lui dis le contrat
c'est il y a aucune obligation si tu es
malheureuse il y a pas de raison que tu
restes là euh moi si ça va pas il y a
aucune raison je suis en vacances aussi
il y a aucune raison donc c'est vraiment
l'une et l'autre on doit décider si on
reste ensemble ou pas et elle et elle a
dit oui oui je comprends j'ai fait une
erreur excuse-moi mais je veux surtout
pas rentrer me ramène pas j'ai dit
d'accord ok et d'ailleurs on sait pas si
on va pas demander à la garder une
semaine de plus quoi parce que c'est un
c'est plaisir c'est un plaisir vraiment
ça va être dur de la ramener mais en
même temps on sait qu'on la laisse dans
un environnement avec beaucoup d'amour
donc ça c'est vraiment très intéressant
mais vous allez avoir la possibilité de
vous revoir oui c'est Awa qui va choisir
nous on est prêt tu es prêt ou
ou même s'il y a pas de
[Musique]
fille y